[Music]
hey everyone its Johanna here when it
comes to overall Fitness stretching
plays a major part and should be given
equal importance as your workouts when
done properly stretching can improve
flexibility reduce post exercise and
muscle soreness enhance your fitness
performance reduce the risk of injury
reduce muscle tension and increase
physical and mental relaxation there are
many different types of stretches
depending on your fitness goal I'll be
sharing two basic stretches which should
be done before and after every workout
session dynamic stretching and static
stretching dynamic stretches means slow
controlled flowing movement rather than
remain still to hold a stretch for
instance hip rotation on circles or leg
swings dynamic stretching should be part
of your warm up but it is not your
warmup you should never stretch a khole
muscle in any way so it is very
important to perform a quick 5 to 10
minutes warm-up prior to stretching this
can be brisk walking jogging much on the
spot or jumping jacks
once your muscles are warm then perform
your structures here are five total body
dynamic stretches which you can do arm
swings lift both arms up by your side
and swing your arms back and forth
across the body as you stretch your
chest and shoulders spend about 30 to 60
seconds on the stretched lunge with
rotation lunge forward and rotate your
body toward the forward leg remember to
keep your core tight and body upright
step back and repeat with the other leg
performed ten to chop repetitions on
each side this stretches your glutes hip
flexor and cuffs high kicks then show
them with a pot and place your left arm
in front of you swing your right leg
gently and aim for your right toes to
at the palm of your hand do not Benghazi
keep your leg straight and you will feel
the stretch on your hand string perform
10 repetitions on one leg and switch
side hand walks stand shoulder-width
apart slowly bent forward unto your
hands touch the ground walk your hands
forward until your body is always
parallel with the ground then slowly
walk your feet back up to your hands
repeat 6 times it is important to keep
your legs straight throughout and you
will feel the stretch in your hand
strings shoulders and core scorpion-like
only stomach with your arms stretched
out by your side gently keep your right
foot towards your left arm and then your
left food towards your right arm perform
tend to trap repetitions on each side
this is great for those of you who have
a tight lower back or previous lower
back injury as it stretches your lower
back and hip flexor you should never do
static stretches before a workout this
may decrease your power energy and
performance because it is meant to relax
your muscles on that note let's get into
static stretching static stretching is
when you hold a position for a certain
period of time there is no movement or
bouncing in the stretch static
stretching should only be done after a
workout session it is meant to lengthen
stretch and relax a muscle and to also
reduce your heart rate and body
temperature if you're looking to
maintain your current level of
flexibility then hold a stretch for 10
to 20 seconds and repeat 2 to 3 times if
you're looking to increase your
flexibility level then hold a stretch
for at least 30 seconds to
sixty seconds or more and repeat two to
three times you have to stretch at least
once a day or multiple times in a day
every time you stretch you have to
perform your warmup
never ever stretch on cold muscles
remember to breathe deeply into your
muscles when holding a stretch relax
without and try to reach a little
further and tumult discomfort but do not
over stretch stretching later on in the
day can have a greater effect on
flexibility in comparison to early
mornings because our range of motion is
greater and that is why we tend to have
tightened muscles in the morning please
watch my video here for a quick total
body active static stretches which you
can perform after your workout sessions
to conclude stretching tends to be under
emphasized in a lot of training but
remember that it is as important as your
workouts it doesn't take long at all
spending only five minutes before and
after each workout session to stretch
will make a huge difference to your
overall fitness performance long term so
remember to do your dynamic stretches
before you workout and your static
stretches after every workout session
all the best for new fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my You Tube channel and
website do you follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you